der spanier hatte die ganze welt auf das
erstmalige treffen von us-präsident rang
und nordkoreas diktator kim jong un im
juni 2018
zweifellos ein herausragendes
geopolitisches ereignis doch können die
damit verbundenen erwartungen auch
erfüllt werden heute in vechta kompakt
nordkorea
alles nur show der gipfel brachte eine
gemeinsame erklärung hervor die unter
anderem vier wesentliche punkte enthält
die usa und nordkorea verpflichten sich
neue beziehungen zwischen den beiden
ländern aufzubauen
beide staaten werden sich gemeinsam für
den aufbau eines dauerhaften und
stabilen friedens regimes auf der
koreanischen halbinsel einsetzen
nordkorea bekräftigte die erklärung von
bahn und schon vom 27 april 2008 sein
und verpflichtet sich auf eine
vollständige denuklearisierung der
koreanischen halbinsel hinzuarbeiten
die usa und nordkorea verpflichten sich
zur bergung sterbliche überreste von
kriegsgefangenen und vermissten
einschließlich der sofortigen
rückführung bereits identifizierte
personen wie ist das nun zu bewerten was
ist davon zu halten dazu ein kleiner
rückblick
es handelt sich nicht um den ersten
versuch einer annäherung
seit 1985 haben die usa und die
staatengemeinschaft versucht nordkorea
zur einstellung seines nuklearprogramms
unserer raketenentwicklung und zur
aufgabe des exports diverser
technologien zu bewegen
vor allem die 2003 gestarteten sechs
parteien gespräche mit beiden koreas
china russland japan und den usa waren
knapp vor dem durchbruch
nordkorea kündigte 2005 an alle
atomwaffen und das nuklearprogramm
aufzugeben und wieder in den
atomwaffensperrvertrag einzutreten
konkrete schritte sind aber unterblieben
2009 scheiterten die verhandlungen weil
man sich vor allem auf die art und weise
des überprüfungsprozess nicht einigen
konnte und nordkorea einen raketentest
durchführte was ist jetzt anders
die erklärung vom juni 2018 kommt
halte ich bei weiten nicht an die
vereinbarungen der sechs parteien
gespräche von 2005 heran
man scheint wieder von vorne zu beginnen
allerdings könnten andere vorzeichen
bestehen da beide präsidenten ein
starkes persönliches interesse an einem
fortschritt haben dürften
ein treffen in singapur wurden zwar eine
allgemeine absichtserklärungen abgegeben
ohne substanzielle konkrete schritte zu
vereinbaren aber auch das erregt bereits
große internationale aufmerksamkeit
die tragweite der gespräche zwischen den
usa und nordkorea geht nämlich weit über
das atomwaffenprogramm hinaus es könnte
zum beispiel zu geänderten
machtverhältnisse in der region ostasien
um den pazifischen raum insgesamt kommen
so würde der von präsident frank in
aussicht gestellte abzug etwa 30.000 us
soldaten eine verschiebung das
kräftegleichgewicht zum nachteil der usa
bedeuten
das könnte nicht nur südkorea sondern
auch japan in eine missliche lage
bringen
china hingegen würde von einem abzug
profitieren und könnte seine position in
der region ausbauen
japan übte daher spontan deutliche
kritik und bemängelte besonders die
fehlende verifizierung und kontrolle
bisher argumentierte trump premiere mit
wirtschaftlichen aspekten die
stationierung der us truppen seit teuer
die stationierung der us bomber auf der
pazifikinsel guam und deren
demonstrations- flüge in der region
würden viel geld verschlingen
geostrategische überlegungen
diskussionen sind jedoch unerlässlich
weil der einfluss der usa in der region
deutlich abnehmen könnte außerdem werden
sicherlich japan südkorea und andere
staaten der region ihre bedenken dem
weißen haus zur kenntnis bringen
worauf ist die nächster zeit zu achten
bisherige aussagen deuten darauf hin
dass beide seiten ernsthaft an einer
lösung interessiert sind
es gibt auch schon ernste warnrufe dass
nordkorea ein falsches spiel treiben
konkret ist daher in nächster zeit auf
folgende punkte zu beachten
inhaltlich welche gesprächs formate
werden vereinbart kann man sich auf den
weg einigen hat man die gleiche
inhaltliche vorstellung von
demokratisierung wie erfolgskontrolle
und über
prüfung weiters werden die us manöver
tatsächlich ausgesetzt
gibt es sonstige entspannungssignale zum
beispiel gegenseitige besuchsprogramm
wie verfährt man mit den sanktionen und
wie werden andere staaten eingebunden
ein kurzer ausblick grundsätzlich ist
der ansatz für eine verhandlungslösung
sehr zu begrüßen vorsicht und
zurückhaltung sind aber angebracht
aufgrund der bisherigen erfahrungen
ergeben sich grob drei folgende
entwicklungsoptionen option eins die
gespräche werden mühsam langwierig und
holprig aber erfolgreich sein
option 2 es kommt zu einem einseitigen
rückzug der usa oder nordkoreas option
drei negative entwicklungen in der
region führen zur aussetzung oder
beendigung der gespräche
derzeit sind alle optionen offen auf den
punkt gebracht könnte man sagen der zug
ist abgefahren er hatte aber den bahnhof
noch nicht verlassen
[Musik]